hello and welcome to my very first uh
video update i hope you enjoy hearing
about all of the initiatives and
projects that we're working on across
northeast derbyshire over the coming
weeks and months
like many of you i've been deeply moved
by the distressing images that we've
seen coming out of afghanistan you may
have heard that the prime minister's
recently announced the operation warm
welcome is now underway and that's to
welcome afghan rivals into the uk
particularly those who supported the
uk during the conflict as well as their
families and evacuees who are at highest
risk
of reprisals and we're working to ensure
that they're supported as they rebuild
their lives over in the uk we've also
been pressing ahead with many new
projects to improve the lives of both
residents and visitors to our beautiful
part of derbyshire
we're investing a massive 1.9 million
pounds in kilometer sports centre and
creating even more facilities for
residents and visitors to enjoy
the works are going to start later on
this month and the improvements include
a large 80 station gym
fitness studios
a cafe
the creation of a large multi-story soft
play area
providing additional changing places
toilets and making the centre accessible
for non-sporting customers and a great
asset for the whole community for
everyday general use or to host
children's parties now keeping on the
subject of legislators we've also
received a humbling and heartfelt thanks
from the staff at the nhs who've been
working closely with our teams
at charlie park leisure centre which as
you will know has been a vaccination
centre for the last eight months
the vaccination operation has now moved
out of the centre and after incredibly
supporting 60 000 people in this
district to be vaccinated and saving
thousands of lives in the process
kate chilton the general manager of the
nhs operation who's been running the
vaccination program said i would like to
take this opportunity to thank you for
having us on site and nedc for providing
the facilities over the past eight
months
thank you to the whole team who have
been proactively supporting the campaign
and worked closely with the vaccination
team to make our stay with you run like
clockwork we absolutely couldn't have
achieved the mammoth 60 000 vaccinations
without your support
we're also investing 1.5 million pounds
in eckington swimming pool and fitness
centre
which will slash its carbon emissions by
66 percent and make it one of the
greenest leisure centres in the area the
project supports our efforts to
decarbonize energy sources in public
buildings to achieve net zero by 2030.
this includes the use of solar power
technology replacing gas-powered boilers
with air source heat pumps and a new air
handling system that will improve air
quality and will increase temperatures
in the pool for customers in the
building on the subject of technology
i'm delighted that we're now able to
help people develop their digital skills
through the new digital inclusion
project digital connect
free digital training is being offered
to residents who live in north east
derbyshire age 50 and above
more information about this can be found
on our website
as well as looking after our residents
our businesses are a key focus for us as
we move through the pandemic and beyond
from now until the end of november we're
encouraging businesses to share their
views to identify the skills they need
to help them thrive and grow
the business skills audit can be
completed now via our website so please
make sure that you have your say
our website and social media channels
also have updates about all the latest
fundraising that our chairman councillor
thaka is doing for ashgate hospice care
as well as some brilliant news about a
national accolade that the street scene
team have been awarded
so please do have a look and remember to
sign up to receive all the latest
updates from us so that you don't miss
out on our news and views and offers
from north east derbyshire district
council
when so many events have had to be
cancelled because of cobit i'm delighted
we're now able to commemorate our
commitment to the armed forces covenant
and pay tribute to our armed forces
community
please join us for this very special
armed forces celebration event which
will be held from 11 a.m to 3 p.m on
sunday the 3rd of october at drumfield
sports centre adjoining far water lane
car park more information will be on our
website and social media so please do
keep checking for the details
finally if you'd like to find out even
more about the work of the council and
our housing partner come along to one of
our meet the council events which will
be taking place on the 27th of september
at eckington civic center and on the 5th
of october at charlie park leisure
centre in clay cross both events run
from 5 30 to 7 30 p.m and will give
visitors the chance to speak with
officers and counsellors and raise
queries about services and find out
about our online services get advice and
guidance and quiz myself
fellow cabinet members and senior
officers on any issues that are
affecting your community finally before
i go i just would also like to welcome
councillors stratford stevenson and
councillor lacey who were successful
following the recent by-elections
and welcome to them to the council and
look forward to working with them thanks
very much for watching our video update
i hope you found it really useful but
please do give us any feedback on any
other issues you might like us to cover
and hopefully you'll you'll see from us
very very soon
you